[Music]
on this thursday night remembering a
remarkable
mother she's really delivered
environmental engineering solutions to
the world
tributes pour in for madiha salman
killed in the london attack
plus new details on the suspect giving
up on the green party why this mp is
joining the liberals
the ripple effects of killing keystone
xl the impact on oil producers
alberta's beleaguered premier and his
1.5 billion dollar investment
plus trash talk the seven main
characters of the
g7 conference the mountainous sculpture
and the message behind it
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with developments in the murder
investigation in london ontario
the man accused of running down and
killing four members of the same family
appeared in court today there is new
information about the suspect including
what his parents divorce proceedings
reveal about him
and the relatives of those who were
killed say they want to remain private
we are getting a clearer picture of
their role in the community
mike draulie has our top story tonight
nathaniel veltman appeared in court
virtually a grainy picture of a young
man accused of a heinous act of violence
in his hometown of strathroy he went
largely unnoticed he and his family were
known at bethel baptist church
but hadn't attended in years and even
students who were in the same grade as
he was in high school
barely remember him people talk around
town like
everybody knows everybody's name but
nobody really knows
the people i guess court documents from
his parents divorce
provide some details they reveal his
mother often locked the door to her room
to avoid her son's badgering and
argumentative behavior
and he wasn't allowed to be around his
five siblings including his twin sister
without supervision
his father released the family's first
public statement since the killings
today saying
it was with utmost shock and horror that
it came to hear of the unspeakable crime
committed last weekend
there are no words adequate to properly
express my deep sorrow
for the victims of this senseless act
for the afsaha family and their loved
ones grief colors
every attempt at remembrance as tragic a
story as it is
friends of the apsols don't want them
remembered for this nondescript
stretch of road western university
engineering professor jason gerhard
recruited madiha salman as a graduate
student in 2008.
she was enthusiastic he said and ready
to embrace life in canada from the start
she said oh you don't need to worry
about me i have so much energy
nothing can stop me and she said you
know
in my undergraduate degree in pakistan
i was the only woman in a class of 174
students and she excelled at western
developing a technology to remove
toxins from contaminated soil it's been
used to clean up toronto's waterfront
what she's done is is you know part of a
larger picture
but she's really delivered environmental
engineering solutions to the world
she was remarkable he says an adjective
used often to describe the assault
family
dr ahmed hegazi hasn't been able to talk
about what happened to his friends
until now he sees them as remarkable in
death
as they were in life i want this family
remembered
as the family that would not
want in this situation had salman been
alive with us now
he wouldn't have asked for revenge he
would have said
fight evil with good and so when you do
that
your enemy will become your friend and a
multi-faith march will be held tomorrow
night starting at seven o'clock
it will travel seven kilometers to the
london mosque aiming to arrive at
8 45 p.m to coincide with the time of
the attack on sunday
we're also learning the funerals will be
held on saturday part of which will be
open to the public sadly nine-year-old
faye is the only survivor of the attack
won't be able to attend because
he's still in hospital donna
a remarkable family mike trolley in
london ontario thanks
now to the pandemic and a warning in
ontario new cases are
dropping rapidly but the highly
transmissible delta variant remains a
wild card
new modeling shows it will likely become
dominant in ontario by early summer
whether a fourth wave can be avoided
depends on vaccines
we need to get more vaccines out quickly
and we need to move quickly into second
doses to help fight the delta variant
ontario is accelerating the rollout of
second doses in some hot spot regions
the delta variant is much more
contagious and can make people sicker
about 63 percent of canadians have now
had at least
one dose which is great progress but
that's not enough protection against the
delta variant
two doses are needed and less than 10
percent of canadians have had both
as heather urix west explains that makes
reopening plans
risky it's a day many in alberta have
been waiting
for under stage two of the province's
reopening plan
going to the movies indoor dining or a
dip
in the local pool is possible once again
alberta is hoping to remove
all restrictions soon stage three
clearing the way for the start of the
calgary stampede
in less than a month's time we are not
planning on
setting any attendance records at this
year's stampede
but as well we will have all the thrills
and spills of
calgary stampede but alberta's former
chief medical officer of health still
believes that is a bad
idea as cases of the more highly
transmissible delta variant
rise if i were living in calgary one of
the things that would concern me
is that 85
of the delta variant that's been
found in the province is being found in
calgary right now ontario is testing
half of all positive cases for the delta
variant
identifying 434 cases as of its last
update on june
3rd in western canada bc alberta and
saskatchewan
are now screening all positive samples
for delta with more than 200 cases
detected in alberta and more than
500 in bc to further stop the spread of
covet 19
and support delta hot spots we are
further expanding booking eligibility
for an accelerated second dose in select
regions across the province starting
monday ontario residents living in areas
where delta is spreading through the
community can book a second dose
alberta and bc have accelerated its
second dose rollout too
but in alberta the demand for first
doses has hit a plateau
about one hundred thousand short of the
province's seventy percent goal
even if somebody gets a vaccine today
it's still a minimum of two weeks before
they get the full protection of the
vaccine
as easing restrictions raised the stakes
on another round
of the vaccine variant race heather urex
west global news
calgary leaders of some of the world's
wealthiest nations including canada
are in cornwall england tonight for
their first in-person
g7 meeting in almost two years before it
started
u.s president joe biden met with
britain's prime minister boris johnson
he reaffirmed america's commitment to
vaccine sharing to help
supercharge the global immunization
effort
the united states will purchase a half a
billion doses
of pfizer kova 19 vaccine to donate to
nearly 100 nations that are in dire need
in the fight against this pandemic
that is on top of the 80 million vaccine
doses the u.s has already pledged by the
end of this month
most of the big decisions and agreements
are reached before these meetings
actually happen but the face-to-face
talks formal and informal between the
leaders
matter too there are big topics to
address including climate change in the
pandemic
abigail beeman is traveling with the
prime minister abigail
donna before even boarding the plane
everyone needed to have
one dose of the vaccine a temperature
check and a negative
pcr test and when i told the person who
took my information at the test clinic
where the prime minister was headed she
said
does he know it's covered so clearly
some mixed opinions on the decision to
travel overseas
my brother just lost all his legs and
all his fingers jonathan mason feels
helpless
closed borders means he can't visit his
brother in the u.s
but he still supports the person who
closed the borders
in crossing them i think it's very
important that he starts to show the
world that
that we're not going to let this virus
control us justin trudeau is
representing canada overseas for the
first time since the pandemic began to
the uk
for the g7 and then to brussels for nato
and an eu
summit about half a dozen people from
the prime minister's office are taking
flight
everyone including the pm will be
subject to regular tests and other
safety protocols
and when they return the two-week
quarantine applies to all
though the conservatives aren't happy
the mandatory hotel stay will be in
ottawa
not one of the four approved cities for
international flights
he shouldn't travel to the u.k he should
stay at the same hotel
that everyone else has to or he should
scrap the hotel quarantine program
there's one person who should be
considered essential it should be our
prime minister a former conservative
foreign affairs minister
says the prime minister shouldn't have
to quarantine at all
let's not be partisan justin trudeau
should be there it's important for
canadians that he's there representing
our country
our values and our interests unlike some
bigger summits the g7 offers more
opportunities for informal connections
critical in person says a former
personal representative to trudeau but
you can have a minute or two just in a
in a corridor or on in a stairwell
as as i have had in the past and work
out
a solution to to a problem senator peter
beam says people aren't as candid or
engaged in virtual meetings due to
security issues
but still for the prime minister who so
often said this
now is not the time to travel the trip
leaves some canadians unimpressed
like this couple regular snowbirds
forced to skip the last trip to florida
you won't let any of us go anywhere and
on that quarantine hotel his office will
only say that he's following public
health guidelines
trudeau himself said he was staying in a
quote government approved airport hotel
but no such venues exist in ottawa
according to the government's own
website
donna abigail beeman thanks
the federal liberals have a new mp the
mp from frederick to new brunswick
jennica atwin who was elected as a green
party member
has abandoned the greens and joined the
liberals the defection leaves the green
party with just two mps in the house of
commons
michael couture is with me from ottawa
mike
well donna with this move the green
party loses one
third of its caucus and someone party
insiders say
could have represented the future of the
green movement
i'm jennica i'm from fredericton and i
have the same priorities
and the same values that i've always had
jennica atwin says she's the same np
but now she has very different political
stripes
the rising star of the greens is leaving
behind a party in turmoil
with a leader who still doesn't have a
seat in the house of commons
there will have to be a lot of soul
searching done within the party to see
why jennica felt this was her only
course of action
and that soul searching will include how
internal divisions have become
very public recently last month when the
green party had called for de-escalation
in the middle east and a return to
dialogue
in a tweet atwood labeled her leader's
statement as
totally inadequate saying she stood with
palestinians and called for an
end to apartheid i mentioned distraction
it's been really difficult to focus on
the important work that needs to be done
on behalf of my constituents
so it certainly has played a role the
longtime liberal who helped announce
atwin's defection says the party is
welcoming her
and her views with open arms in the
liberal caucus
there is enormous room for respectful
conversation for differences of opinion
late thursday green party leader anime
paul expressed disappointment at atwin's
departure
but doesn't believe it's a reflection on
her leadership
she wished me well that she hoped that
we would remain friends
and so i will take her at her word that
this is a decision she took
for other reasons the timing of this
couldn't be worse for the greens the
party is losing its star
mp while planning for the possibility of
a fall election
donna all right michael couture thanks
canada's privacy commissioner has
concluded the rcmp seriously breached
privacy laws
by using facial recognition software to
collect the personal
information of canadians the privacy
commissioner daniel therion tabled his
report in parliament today
after investigating the rcmp's use of
the software from
the u.s space company clearview ai the
software cross-references
images of people against billions of
photos taken from the internet without
their consent
the commissioner concluded the use of
facial recognition technology by the
rcmp
to search through massive repositories
of canadians who are innocent
of any suspicion of crime presents a
serious violation of privacy
the rcmp at first denied using clearview
ai but last year admitted
it had been it's still not clear what
for
the domino is now falling that keystone
xl is dead
coming up what it means for alberta's
premier and the taxpayer dollars
he invested
it's been a bad week for alberta premier
jason kenney
first he apologized for floating coveted
rules at a dinner on the sky palace
balcony
new polling shows his approval rating at
a new low
and now the keystone xl pipeline
expansion which he invested in
is officially dead it was first proposed
in 2008
the 1900 kilometer pipeline would have
carried crude from alberta to nebraska
and then tied in with an
existing pipeline carrying crude to the
u.s gulf coast
just last year kenny announced a 1.5
billion dollar investment in the project
and
six billion dollars in loan guarantees
president biden pulled the permits for
the project and yesterday
tc energy canceled it global's tom
vernon is with me
from edmonton tom before we get to
keystone i want to ask you about a
report in an alberta online publication
that premier kenny and others in his
cabinet broke covid19 rules by having
multiple dinners indoors kenny was asked
about that today what did he say
well donna a digital media outlet quotes
unnamed sources inside the ucp
government
that accused the premier of hosting
these dinners at restaurants as well as
at a private resident
while the restrictions were in place not
allowing this to happen now the premier
was
quick to deny these allegations and they
sent a cease and desist letter
to the outlet this is a complete
fabrication and that's why
our legal counsel has written to that
website
demanding a full and immediate
retraction and apology
now the premier global news has not
verified these allegations now the
premier did add that he has had
meals out at restaurants during the
pandemic while the rules did allow to
show support for the industry
he did so either on his own or with one
of his designated close contacts
okay and tom back to keystone now what
happens to the taxpayer money that kenny
invested in and what are the possible
political consequences
yeah donna as of right now alberta
taxpayers are on the hook for about 1.3
billion dollars that's according to the
premier and
the government and tc energy are looking
for ways to recoup some of that cost
from the biden administration on the
premier says alberta has a case to make
under the free trade agreement between
the two countries and we'll learn more
about that
towards the end of july now this comes
as an angus reed poll
shows the premier has the lowest support
for all premiers in the country at 31
and if an election were held today the
opposition ndp would win a majority
government
and to the right of the premier the wild
rose conservative party
would have 20 support donna
all right tom vernon in edmonton thanks
still ahead what you need to know about
another disease carried by ticks
lyme disease which is primarily spread
by deer ticks has received a lot of
attention and has made lots of people
sick
but there is another disease spread by
ticks that is less well known
jamie morocco explains what it is and
why experts say
we should be tracking it here in canada
there we go justin wood is testing ticks
to make sure
others avoid the pain he says one bug
bite has caused him
not really kind of feeling like myself
and pretty much no energy to do anything
ever
after suffering a range of strange
symptoms in 2015
wood was diagnosed with lyme disease it
kind of took my whole life from me
to get it back he started genetics
running a small lab from his southern
ontario home
he looks for pathogens and recently the
33 year old says
he's noticed the emergence of a new
illness we're starting to find that new
species
of the bacteria that causes babesiosis
exist
bobesiosis is caused by babesia a tiny
parasite that affects blood
in canada the first case of babesiosis
was diagnosed in a child in manitoba in
2013.
yale research scientist dr peter krauss
says while it often presents as flu-like
symptoms for some
it can carry up to a 20 risk of death
so people who don't have a spleen people
with cancer people who have hiv aids
and also the extremes of age newborn
infants and
people over the age of 60 tend to have
more severe disease
stateside crow says babesiosis is
already endemic in certain areas thanks
to the growing black-legged tick
population
robin lindsey a scientist at the
national microbiology lab says manitoba
is seeing a potential incursion of
cross-border bugs from minnesota
that's why the infection rate's a bit
higher there but besiosus is found in
five percent of ticks versus one percent
in the rest of the country says lindsay
you're just seeing as a consequence of
tick populations growing
uh into new areas that you're seeing the
emergence of these particular passages
wood has already discovered babesiosis
in ticks in ontario
and expects to soon see it in nova
scotia now he says canada needs more
testing to keep track of the trends
my hope is that we'll have better
treatment
for his disease and the ones to come
jimmy morocco global news toronto
now recycle more next the pressure on g7
leaders to deal with electronic waste
this was a case of swift justice on
tuesday
a man slapped french president emmanuel
macron in the face
today that man was sentenced to four
months in jail the 28 year old claims he
didn't plan to slap
mackerel but says he was filled with
disgust when he saw the president
face to face well macron's face along
with the other g7 leaders are staring
back at them from across the water at
the g7 summit in cornwall
a massive mount rushmore style sculpture
has been created with scraps of
electronic waste
it was commissioned by a british
retailer that sells second-hand
electronics but it does have a political
message
crystal demancing reports
it's a twist on the mounting issue of
electronic waste
and all eyes are now on those who can do
something about it
let's try and build things that we can
repair let's build things that last
longer let's
you know not have to have the new newest
thing every time but
you know let's find a way to dealing
with this before we just get buried
under it
mount recyclemore like many of joe
rush's creations is born of his
environmental and anti-consumerism
beliefs
e-waste may not be top of mind for most
but it has a
huge impact those who work in the world
of recycled electronics
want people to see its weight it's 53
million tons of
of e-waste that's created every year of
which the g7 contributes about
40 percent of that currently a shiny
metal likeness of prime minister justin
trudeau along with his counterparts is
not only
eye-catching nestled along the english
sea side
it's a wake-up call to demand more of
leaders
says this environmentalist time and time
again we come across
cases where they say the right things
and then do the opposite
which is very frustrating
and is sort of abiding time wasting time
when we really need to be making
fundamental changes in the way we live
a fridge or a hoover or you know could
last 20 years it doesn't have to be
thrown away so quickly and
hopefully this will draw people's
attention
to the fact the scrapyard sculpture is
drawing attention
climate is supposed to be a key pillar
of the political gathering
underway in cornwall climate change is
going badly
so countries need to sort it out the
pressure now is on g7
leaders to build lasting policy and not
just reduce urgent environmental issues
to scraps
crystal gomansen global news london
and that's global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen
depending on where you live in canada
you may have seen a stunning sight in
the sky early this morning
it was a ring of fire eclipse the moon
blocked out
all but a sliver of the rising sun some
stunning images
thanks for watching pharah nasser will
be at the anchor desk tomorrow and i'll
see you on saturday for the new
reality take care of yourselves bye-bye